a las vegas woman is raising concerns
tonight after she came across about a
hundred copic 19 test samples along with
a lot of personal information thanks for
staying with us here at 6 30 i'm denise
valdez and i'm brian loftis she found
the bag on dumpster at a local park joe
moeller met up with her he joins us now
in studio with what happened then joe
yeah the personal information has
addresses phone numbers and even social
security numbers i started looking into
this giant bag of samples she had with
her only to end up having more questions
about what this all is from
i found this when i was
at lorenzi park this was on top of the
trash bags susan jerems became concerned
about what she found at the park their
covet tests with people's information
with them there's a box full and a bag
full her big worry was that someone
would take the information but then on
the second page they also have their
social security number she did not want
all this information to get into the
wrong hands i pulled them out of the
dumpster and took them with me i tried
to determine where the tests were done
even calling the names i found on the
paperwork only to find out the people
did not match the numbers i called or
addresses those people tell me they
never had tests done on january 12 2022
it says it's gene matrix
in stone mountain georgia i tried to
contact the number for gene matrix labs
out of georgia the phone number listed
did not work i don't want it sitting in
my park so that's why i took it out as
jerems wonders what could have happened
with this paperwork more questions are
raised about where they came from and
why now i just have to find out what to
do with it
well that stack of tests and paperwork
were turned over to the city's park
department the city tells me it's now in
a secure place the attorney general's
office tells me they are going to look
into that company to see if there's any
complaints associated with it of course
we'll stay on top of this story for you
as well i'll send it back to both of you